Dustin Lynch is one of the hottest
country stars out there since his first
single cowboys and angels debuted back
in 2012 he's racked up seven number one
singles yeah and the hits keep coming
now that Dustin's fourth studio album
has arrived in Sheryl he's also loved
yeah and he met his girlfriend model
Kelly Seymour the old fashioned way you
know by sliding into her DMS
is it true slim through the DMS yeah
that was a two-way street oh really who
first though I went first
and then and then she came in and swung
a couple times and actually I had a
couple of my bad guys kind of pushed me
over the edge
man come on all right I got to a point
life where it was tough for me to meet
I'm sure people because when I first got
started I was able to kind of go out
after shows and and enjoy the town and
go out in social settings bars and
restaurants and things now after your
show just kind of reached a point where
I can't enjoy that anymore and so
meeting people just doesn't happen when
I'm whenever I'm on tour
[Music]
cuz I gotta still can't believe that
congratulations on album number four
thank you so much oh I'm gonna be the
ignorant Canadian let's see if I
pronounced it right
tell the homo nailed it oh yes yeah you
know it's one reason I was kind of
hesitant of naming my album after my
hometown is the spelling of is are
people gonna be able to pronounce for us
and then I realize you know what if they
don't know how to say it they're gonna
google it and that's a message yeah
we're good yeah every single song this
album kind of comes back to my hometown
because my hometown made me who I am
it's why write the songs are right
that's kind of why I believe in what I
believe in and enjoy what I enjoy in
life in our hometowns make us who we are
[Music]
Rony roads another number one do you get
used to it at this point to have a song
reached the top of the charts is just
incredible the amount of people that
hear that song and that songs become a
part of their daily lives and soundtrack
to life is just amazing I don't take it
for granted I don't think I ever will
the new single Mama's house you're like
angry on this song
what's happening sir yeah we haven't
done a legit breakup song yeah on the
radio so to release Mama's houses is
awesome and it's a very powerful song
it's a great country lyric it's it's
when you see the title Momma's House you
don't think no you're gonna get yeah
there's my god Dustin what's what's
happened to you